ايران سيف الزعابي لممارسة مهامه
الدبلوماسية خلال الايام القادمة
زعيم تحالف الفتح هادي العامري
للحوار بشروط ابرزها الانسحاب من
الامدادات الى المانيا عبر خط
انابيب واحد للغاز بين الحادي
تصريحكم? انه فعلا امر مضحك?
اعلن الاليزيه ان الرئيس مانويل
بعد ست سنوات من سحبها له. اذا
لماذا انتم في اليمن يا ابناء
صيانة كشفت وسائل اعلام تركية عن
شروط سورية خمسة مسبقة لتطبيع
الواجب الوطني بل هي دموع الفرح
بعد ان كتب لهم عمر جديد. اعلنت
استمرار القوى السياسية بتجاهل
مطالبه. موسكو تخنق المانيا
وبوتين يحضر لناتو جديد. برأيكم
ما الذي ستحمله لنا الايام
اكثر. اذ اعلنت شركة الطاقة
الروسية العملاقة انها ستوقف
وزارة الخارجية والتعاون الدولي
لدولة الامارات عودة سفيرها الى
اعتقلت الاجهزة الامنية في لبنان
عبدالله سبعاوي حفيد شقيق صدام
قرار من القضاء اللبناني. الصين
تخشى من تصادم عسكري واشنطن
والثلاثين من اغسطس وحتى الثاني
من سبتمبر مرجعة ذلك لعملية
الوثائق المدعومة بنتائج
التحليلات المخبرية التي تثبت
بولاية يوتا الامريكية. فكيف ذلك
على سمعة السلاح الامريكي
حسين. مصادر اعلامية قالت ان
تسليم سبعاوي للعراق بانتظار
جسيم فيها فقد تم اكتشاف خلل في
اداء الخراطيش المسؤولة عن دفع
القذف نعم المسؤول عن دفع الطيار
خارج الطائرة في حال وقوع اي خلل
الاطار وادانة تسريبات رئيس
الوزراء الاسبق نوري المالكي
لكوريا الشمالية اثناء تكريمهم
من قبل الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ
الماضي وذلك خلال عملية فحص
روتينية في قاعدة القوات الجوية
ما تسبب في صدمة عالمية لعشاق
السلاح الامريكي. حيث تتعلق
برأيكم. الاحداث والتطورات. اظهر
مقطع مصور بكاء عسكريين تابعين
كيميائية سامة ضد قواتها في
مقاطعة وانه يجري الان اعداد
العلاقات مع انقرة تتعلق بالوضع
في ادلب والمعابر الحدودية.
ماكرون سيزور الجزائر من الخامس
والعشرين حتى السابع والعشرين من
الكيميائي. فهل تعتقدون ان بوتين
يبحث عن ذريعة ليدخل اسلحته
مبنى عبدالمجيد تبون? اما في
العراق مقتدى الصدر يقبل دعوة
فيما تتوقع مصادر عراقية ان يدعو
مقتدى الصدر لعصيان مدني في حال
المشكلة بمقعد الطوارئ الخاص
بقائد الطائرة او ما يسمى مقعد
زايد? الم تأتوا لمحاربة
الحوثيين اتباع ايران حسب
المقعد ما يمنع الطيارة من
الخروج الامن في حال الطوارئ
الشهر الجاري فما هو الهدف من
هذه الزيارة? وماذا تريدون من
اون مراسم تكريم ليجهشوا بالبكاء
لا اظنها دموع الفرحة بنجاح
شركة تصنيع المقاعد مارتن بيكر
اكتشفت الخلل في شهر ابريل
الاحتفالات بعيد استقلال البلاد
والتي ستكون يوم الاربعاء المقبل
المحرمة خط المعركة? خلل في
الجو. طائرات اف خمسة وثلاثين
بوتين اختراقات جوية وتجسس
بالاقمار الصناعية. والان ترسل
وحتى الاوكرانيين على توخي الحذر
لينتهي صدى في لندن. والتي اعلنت
يعلن عن خلل فني يعلق عمل مئات
الطائرات الحربية من هذا الطراز
اقتراف الجانب الاوكراني ما
وصفته الوزارة بالارهاب
تصريحها باتهام جرثومي. حيث وجهت
اتهاما الاوكرانية باستخدام مواد
عشرة الاف مقاتل اوكراني لتصرح
هنا وزارة الدفاع الروسية وتبدأ
لطالما اسالت لعاب الكثير من
الدول اليوم سلاح الجو الامريكي
عن تجهيز عشرة الاف مقاتل
اوكراني. فماذا تريد بريطانيا من
الشهر. ليصرح زلينسكي ان روسيا
ستقوم بهجوم واسع خلال
اسقاط هذه الطائرات. وهذا هو
الهجوم الثاني من نوعه خلال هذا
حيث تم استهداف المقر الرئيسي
لاسطول البحر الاسود في شبه
الاسود يصل ليتم استقبال هذه
القوة بطائرات اوكرانية مسيرة.
والتي تحمل قوة ضاربة وغواصات لا
تقهر الاسطول الروسي بالبحر
جزيرة القرم الخاضعة للسيطرة
الروسية ليعلن الجانب الروسي عن
يعلنان عن احتمالية وقوع هجوم
على الاراضي الروسية من قبل
سينفس بوتين عن غضبه ويشفي غليل
معلمه ويطفئ نار حزنه. مكالمة
كان من المفترض ان يجلس بسيارة
لكنه غير رأيه وجلس في سيارة
اوكرانيا وانه ان حدث ذلك فسيكون
الرد العسكري اسرع من التصريح
فبماذا سيرد بوتين على هذا
الاختراق الاستخباراتي وكيف
بوتين المرعبة. اتصال هاتفي بين
بوتين وماكرون رائحة التهديدات
الانخراط في الصراع موضحا ان
الولاية المتحدة وحلف الناتو
اخرى قبل لحظات تنفجر السيارة
بابنته ويجثو على ركبتيه ويودع
وزارة الخارجية الروسية واشنطن
لم تستمع جيدا لتحذيراتنا من
المعلومة التي ستسمعها الان. هذا
الشخص هو تلميذ لعالم اسلامي
تفوح منه. بوتين لا نريد ان تصبح
الولايات المتحدة طرفا في الصراع
اظهار الادلة والجهة المنفذة
وخلال اربع وعشرين ساعة فقط.
في الفين واربعة عشر وهو من اعطى
بوتين الضوء الاخضر لاحتلال
المدبر هو الفيلسوف دوجين
والملقب براس بوتين بوسي الجديد.
ابنته. بوتين اعلن حالة الطوارئ
وطلب من الاستخبارات الروسية
السياسي. ومن امواج السياسة
الغاضبة الى امواج البحر الاسود
اوكرانيا. لقد قالها انا منظر
وبوتين مطبق. نعم لا تنصدم بهذه
مع اوكرانيا. واضاف بوتين في
مكالمته الهاتفية والتي صرحت بها
يتحدث اكثر من تسع لغات وصفه
بايدن بدماغ بوتين. يكره
وهو الذي يدير حرب روسيا
اوكرانيا لذا وضعته الولايات
بريطانيا وحلف النيتو وهو من
اشار على بوتين بضم جزيرة القرن
اسمه حيدر جمال ولكن من هذا
الشخص الذي يمثل عقل ورأس روسيا
المتحدة الامريكية في رأس قائمة
العقوبات. لقب بالرجل الغامض
اغتيال عقل بوتين. هو معلم بوتين
وقدوته. بل هو عقل بوتين المدبر
الصين في المحيط الهادئ المضطرب
توقيت مثالي قد يستغله بوتين.
تايوان ستكون كارثة حقيقية
بالنسبة للغرب ليدخل بوتين ويصرح
الهواتف النقالة الى السيارات
والطائرات. فاذا سيطرت الصين على
ايه ؟ وللمرة الثالثة تقولها
امريكا ماذا ستفعلون يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقة؟ لا تخبروني انكم
ستعملون على تنفيذ مناورة
الرئيسي لتصنيع اي جهاز الكتروني
موجود على سطح الكرة الارضية من
تسيطر على تسعين بالمائة منها
عالميا. الشرائح هي المصدر
وحسب مصادر اقتصادية الصين تسعى
لضم تايوان من اجل الشرائح
رئيس الصين شي جين بينغ. نشعر
بالقلق من ان التوتر المتصاعد مع
ان تايوان اوكرانيا الجديدة
ملمحا عن نيتو جديد يتشكل بقيادة
الالكترونية التي تعد تايوان
المصدر الاكبر لها في العالم حيث
واشنطن بشأن تايوان قد يؤدي الى
مواجهة عسكرية غير مقصودة. هنا
الزيارة الثالثة. وكما يقول
اخواننا المصريون هي وكالة ولا
عسكرية. فما ذنب السمك في البحر؟
ليأتي هنا الرد الصيني على لسان
رجل. فيما سبق زيارة الباسوس
نانسي بيلوسي يليها زيارة مجموعة
عبدالمجيد تبون. امريكا تتحدى
الصين. وصل حاكم ولاية انديانا
الدولي. وزيارة للرئيس الفرنسي
للجزائر فماذا تريد فرنسا ابناء
الامريكية الى العاصمة
التايوانية تايبيه مهلا مهلا يا
يضع واشنطن في ورطة والامارات
تغضب السعودية بهذا الفعل. بينما
العراق يتجاهز لحرب اهلية حفيد
شقيق صدام في قبضة الانتربول
من اعضاء الكونجرس. واليوم حاكم
ولاية انديانا الامريكية وهي
اوكرانيا فكيف سترد موسكو غلل
تقني في طائرات اف خمسة وثلاثين
للقصف من طرف مجهول وبريطانيا
ترسل عشرة الاف مقاتل الى
بين بوتين وماكرون تغضب
الامريكان؟ الاسطول الروسي يتعرض
سنذهب لتايوان وللمرة الثالثة
فماذا انتم فاعلون يا اصحاب
بوتين يتعرض لعملية اغتيال؟ فمن
الفاعل؟ ومكالمة هاتفية مسربة
العيون الضيقة؟ هكذا قالت
امريكا؟ فبماذا سترد بكين وعقل
القادمة?